GOES THAT WAY I WOULD SAY.
BUCK SEXTON, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
IN HER 2016 CONCESSION SPEECH,
LAKE CLINTON VOUCHED TO CHAMPION
THE CAUSE OF WOMEN IN POLITICS.
>> I KNOW WE HAVE STILL NOT
SHATTERED THAT HIGHEST AND
HARDEST GLASS CEILING BUT
SOMEDAY, SOMEONE WILL AND
HOPEFULLY SOONER THAN WE MIGHT
THINK RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: WELL, SHE CLEARLY
THOUGHT ABOUT RUNNING AGAIN IN
2020.
NO ONE IN HER CORPORATE WANT HER
TO AND SO FAR SHE HAS STAYED OUT
BUT SHE SEEMS TO BE DETERMINED
TO REMAIN IN THE PUBLIC EYE AND
SO THIS WEEK, HILLARY CLINTON
AND HER DAUGHTER CHELSEA, WHO
WAS INCREDIBLY IMPRESSIVE, SHE
WENT TO STANFORD COME ON LIKE
YOU, WILL BE RELEASING A NEW
BOOK HONORING QUOTE, GUTSY
WOMEN.
>> THE BOOK OF GUTSY WOMEN IS
FILLED WITH ASSAYS THAT ARE
REFLECTIONS OF OUR FEELINGS
ABOUT THESE WOMEN, WHAT WE THINK
OF THEM.
>> WE THINK IT'S ALWAYS A GREAT
TIME TO BE CELEBRATING AND
LEARNING FROM AND BEING INSPIRED
BY GUTSY WOMAN.
>> SPUN AND SETTING, IT'S
FRESHMAN, I THINK IT'S BEEN
PARTICULARLY FRUSTRATING FOR
CHELSEA.
>> Tucker: TAMMY BRUCE IS THE
PRESIDENT OF INDEPENDENT WOMEN'S
VOICE AND REASON ENOUGH TO
SUBSCRIBE TO THE SERVICE.
SHE JOINS US NOW.
TO MAKE HIM EXPLAIN FOR ME IF
YOU COULD WHY I FELT PHYSICALLY
NAUSEOUS WATCHING THE CLIP WE
JUST PLAYED.
>> YOU AREN'T THE ONLY ONE.
THIS IS WATCHING THESE TWO WOMEN
ON THEIR PURCHASE OF PROGRESSIVE
PRIVILEGE MAKING A DETERMINATION
ABOUT WHO IS WORTHY OF BEING
SPOKEN ABOUT OR WRITTEN ABOUT.
YOU KNOW, IF THEY HAD ANY GUTS,
WHICH THEY DON'T, THEY WOULD
WRITE A BOOK ABOUT THE GREATNESS
OF MARGARET THATCHER.
THAT IS UNDENIABLE.
IT'S CLEARLY A POLITICAL
POSITION THAT THEY HAVE NOT
NECESSARILY AGREED WITH BUT IT'S
PART OF BEING A GREAT LEADER IS
BEING ABLE TO RECOGNIZE THE
VALUE OF OTHER PEOPLE BUT
CERTAINLY OF FEMINISM.
IT SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT ALL
WOMEN AND OPENING THE DOORS TO
WHOEVER WE WANT TO BECOME AND
WHATEVER WE WANT TO DO FOR A
LIVING BUT OF COURSE, AS HE SAT
THERE AT THE SHOW, YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
FRAUDS.
THEY ARE NOT WHAT THEY SAY THEY
ARE.
AND THIS IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
THAT.
SO OF COURSE, THEY WILL
HIGHLIGHT PEOPLE THAT THEY AGREE
WITH, THEY WILL NOT HIGHLIGHT
WOMEN LIKE MARGARET THATCHER OR
MELANIA TRUMP WHO THE ENTIRE
FEMINIST MOVEMENT HAS WORKED
VERY HARD TO IGNORE.
THEY ARE THE MEAN GIRLS
CELEBRATING THEMSELVES SO IT
DOESN'T TAKE MUCH GUTS TO BE
THERE AND TO EXPERIENCE AND
ENJOY YOUR PROGRESSIVE
PRIVILEGE.
TO HAVE THAT PRODUCTION.
THAT LARGESS AND TO PUT YOUR
NOSE UP AND SNIFF AT EVERYONE
ELSE BUT IT ALSO A MESSAGE ABOUT
WHO REALLY COUNTS HERE THAT YOU
WILL ONLY COUNT IF THEY TOUCH
YOU AND DECIDE THAT YOU ARE A
PERSON WHO IS WORTHY OF THEIR
ATTENTION.
THEY ARE PASSE.
THEY ARE OF COURSE AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT IS NOT FEMINISM AND WHAT
WOMEN SHOULD NOT BECOME AND THAT
IS WHY HILLARY CLINTON DID NOT
WIN AND WE WILL HAVE A WOMEN
PRESIDENT AND THAT WOMAN WILL BE
CONSERVATIVE AND SHE WILL DO A
GOOD JOB BEING THE PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT'S A
PREDICTION THAT IS LIKELY TO
COME TRUE.
REALLY QUICK, WHAT'S THE POINT
OF THIS QUESTION MIKE THESE ARE
TWO WOMEN THAT HAVE HAD A LOT OF
SUCCESS DOING I'M NOT EXACT THEY
SHOW UP WITH A MADE OF A TON OF
MONEY.
THEY ARE RICH AS HELL.
WHY ARE THEY DOING IT, DO YOU
THINK?
>> IT IS CERTAINLY FOR THE
ATTENTION BUT YOU KNOW, CHELSEA
IS GOING TO NEED TO HAVE A JOB
AND SHE'S NOT GOING TO WANT TO
WORK IN A CORPORATION I'M SURE
OR GO SOMEWHERE NINE TO FIVE
LIKE MOST AMERICANS.
THEY EXPECT CHELSEA TO TAKE ON
THAT MANTLE BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THEY DO SEE THIS COUNTRY AS A
COMPANY THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
INHERITED AND NOW THEY ARE
WORKING VERY HARD TO WORK MAKE
SURE THE UNDESERVING, THOSE WHO
DO NOT CONFORM TO THE LIBERAL
AGENDA, ARE PUSHED ASIDE.
AND I THINK THAT THIS IS MORE
THAN ANYTHING ABOUT CHELSEA AND
OF COURSE, SHE WILL BE
DISAPPOINTED.
CHELSEA HAS THE POTENTIAL, I
SUPPOSE, I'M DELIVERING BUT ONLY
IF SHE BECOMES, I THINK I'M ON
HER OWN PERSON AND IF SHE
HERSELF IS WILLING TO CHALLENGE
THE STATUS QUO THAT HER PARENTS
AND DEMOCRATS LIKE HER HAVE
MOVED FORWARD FOR NOW A COUPLE
GENERATIONS.
SHE COULD BE THE ONE WHO BREAKS
OUT.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THAT BUT I
DON'T EXPECT IT.
>> Tucker: KNOW.
YEAH.
I MEAN, SHE WENT TO STANFORD AND
WORK AHEAD PUNCH HEDGE FUND.